bueno pues efectivamente no sólo es eeuu
también méxico y los demás países han
contribuido en tratar de frenar la
migración sin embargo los factores de
empuje que obligan a cientos de
migrantes como cada día a migrar como lo
vemos en esta caravana que se organizó
el día de hoy que viene desde san pedro
sula pues siguen esos factores de empuje
tan solo pensando en el lugar donde se
origina esta nueva caravana de 2022 san
pedro sula está en la lista de los
primeros 5 países este 5
sitios con mayor violencia homicida en
el mundo ciudades de mayor violencia
homicida en el mundo del o en los
últimos 10 años entonces es como veíamos
en los testimonios de algunos de los que
acompañan esta caravana los motivos
siguen siendo la falta de oportunidades
la pobreza extrema y ahora cada vez más
también el tema de la violencia homicida
y por supuesto lo que sea también
agravado con el tema de la crisis
sanitaria que ha golpeado más fuerte a
las personas que menos tienen y bueno
también
muchos desastres naturales que hemos
visto en la región entonces creo que el
principal motivo a pesar de las amenazas
es que los factores de puja siguen y las
personas prefieren correr el riesgo del
mobbing y de la amenaza de no entrar por
la la militarización de fronteras
etcétera que seguir en las condiciones y
algunos de ellos con amenazas de vida
señor alrededor el gobierno bailén ha
prometido ayudas a los países
centroamericanos precisamente para
evitar este tipo de situaciones cree que
hay una falla en estas estrategias y si
las hay donde radican están en
washington o en los países en cuestión
mira creo que el principal tema en ir a
las causas de la migración que no sólo
es el gobierno vayan también por méxico
se está haciendo un plan es que en lo
que llegamos a estas pautas de estos
orígenes la gente va a seguir migrando
esta es una estrategia de largo alcance
y creo que a la par tenemos que tener
estrategias de cómo colaborar y cómo
ayudar y apoyar y tener un sistema
migratorio más ordenado y que pueda
apoyar a los que hoy van a seguir
migrando en lo que es estas estrategias
logran cualquier tipo de éxito pues bien
eunice rendón coordinadora de agenda
migrante y recibirán muchas gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en france 24